at the crime scene
the area where these terrible events
happened yesterday with my colleagues
forensic teams and privacy managers
[Music]
rest assured our team's professional and
led up to the events yesterday I'd like
to thank people in the local area in
general for perseverance
accepting we must do our job correctly
properly at the scene like this and
although we've managed to release a lot
of the roads under bridge station is
running we will of course be here for
some time to come examining privacy
yesterday as well as all that horror we
witnessed the most extraordinary courage
by members of the public and it leads
the City of London and other police
officers and emergency services we saw
some wonderful examples very best
I hope you realize just how much our
people are doing now right across
largest in reviewing all the events we
have another try to make sure that we
we also have been reaching out to people
in our communities providing I'm not
going I'm not going to talk about who
you what about what for for hands I
don't think that's appropriate it's not
the priority at the moment the
investigation is obviously piecing all
these things together
you